hey guys welcome back as many of you may
know i've been here
in dimension quinn tirelessly working
away on my ultimate guide to chapter
house dune video
and i decided that before i put out that
video i should do a preamble video
to discuss some of the themes and
philosophies present in that book
so without further ado let's get into it
what now this is boring are you going to
keep me trapped here at least talk about
something interesting
philosophy is interesting only to you i
want to know who has the biggest laser
sword in dune there are no laser swords
in the dune universe or who can do the
most reps with gravity cubes
what series are you even reading cause
it's not dude i know
if you put all the characters in a death
match who would win no
organism that silly actually
maybe not it might actually be
interesting to discuss
power in the dune universe but not in
the typical sense
political or economic in the sense of
raw power
and raw skill finally something
interesting okay guys what do you say
we'll talk about philosophy some other
time
but for today
[Music]
[Applause]
there'll be a few minor spoilers in this
one guys as i said earlier
power in dune is not typically discussed
in these terms
but considering the fact that there are
several characters in the dune universe
who would seem super human if they were
to appear in real life
maybe it's actually an interesting topic
so i thought it would be fun to rank the
characters
let's go from least powerful to most
powerful
also i will only be discussing frank
herbert's original six dune books for
this video
number eight the lady jessica the lady
jessica
mother of paul atreides was immensely
skilled and even a standout among the
benny jesuit
jessica was one of the results of the
bini jesuits millennia-long breeding
program
her powers included voice the sisterhood
skill of manipulative speech
which would appear as mind control to
the average person
she was also gifted in the weirding way
the mini jesuit martial arts
which allowed near teleportation in
close quarters
jessica's weirding way saves her life in
the desert among the fremen
jessica's gifts also include all the
benny jesuit powers of internal chemical
control
which would make her almost entirely
immune to poisons
number seven aaliyah aaliyah was the
pre-born daughter of jessica
she had all of jessica's gifts and
memories the problem was however that
aaliyah had difficulty managing the
multitude of lives that lived within her
i've often said that leah is one of the
most tragic characters in dune
there are other pre-born characters
which managed to control their inner
lives with help
but aaliyah was abandoned by her mother
who feared her
with no one to guide her she succumbed
to the will of her inner lives
her power is in fact ultimately a curse
oh i guess power's not always a good
thing huh no
it's not raw power is often destructive
even to its wilder number six the final
version of duncan idaho
the version of duncan idaho that appears
in heretics and chapter house dune
is a long ways away from the sword's
master of the original novel
this gola version of duncan was trained
by the benny jesuit sisterhood
and given access to all of their
knowledge saved the arcana
in heretics of dune the memories of his
past self are awakened
duncan even develops a form of
prescience which ends up saving him from
being captured
by the mysterious lifeforms known as
daniel and marty
in addition to this it is pointed out
that this version of duncan had been
upgraded by the delaxou
and no longer had the physical
limitations of the version of duncan
which appeared in god emperor of dune
number five
odrade in the original dune series
odrade was a descendant of paul atreides
and a gifted benny jesuit sister who
eventually would become the mother
superior
o'draid was immune to prescient power as
were all the descendants of siona
atreides
due to later the second's no gene that
means that she could not be seen by the
oracle
she also possessed the wild talent a
limited form of prescience
which guided her in times of great need
audrey possessed all the powers of
jessica only refined by
thousands of years of continued bini
jesuit genetic tinkering
odrade is by far the most skilled benny
jesuit sister
to ever appear in the series and it's
more than likely
given frank herbert's writing style and
the nature of the benny jesuit
that her power is actually understated
i can't wait to talk more about o'draid
in my ultimate guide to chapter house
dune video
number four miles tay miles take
is another descendant of paul atreides
and o'draid's father
he was said to be the spitting image of
the original duke lately
paul's father like paul atreides tegg
was taught the benny jesuit ways
secretly by his mother he was one of the
sisterhood's most valuable tools
in heretics of dune tag's full power is
awakened
after being tortured by the honored
montrese tag evolves into a new state of
being
single-handedly he slaughters everyone
in the matre building
moving so swiftly to all others he would
appear as a mere blur
once the sisterhood recognized the
potential of his genes
they had him brought back as a gola
after his death on arrakis
slaughtering humans now this actually
seems cool
organism why do you hate me in my
species so much because you literally
destroyed my homeworld with billions of
inhabitants and imprisoned me here
oh yeah i did do that anyway number
three
the og paul atreides paul's power as
oppressions were only second to his son
paul was of course trained in the mini
jesuit way and awakened by the spice
essence in the deserts of arrakis
paul possessed the genetic memories of
both his paternal and maternal ancestors
but everyone knows about paul so let's
not spend too long on him
number two daniel and marty i chose to
place daniel and marty at
2 because though they are obviously very
powerful
we don't know actually how powerful they
are
in the original dune universe they
appear at the end of chapter house tune
an attempt to capture the inhabitants of
the nosh
they have some way of watching the
events of humanity from afar
and seem totally unfazed by the goings
on in the empire
it is heavily implied that the pair are
hyper-evolved lala su-face dancers
which freed themselves from slavery by
gathering enough human memories
to be able to outsmart their masters
i've actually done an entire video on
daniel and marty
which you can watch here number one you
guessed it
later the second the god emperor lato
like aaliyah was born into the world
possessing
all of the memories of his ancestors as
a child
he ventured into the desert and sought
out legendary jackaroo too
it was there in the desert that he
stepped forward on the path
which would set everything in motion
once his mind had been awakened by the
spice essence
he joined with the sand trout creating a
living skin suit
it gave him the strength of a hundred
men speed
like no other but this was not the end
the skin evolved and grew and later
developed into the worm god emperor
his body now produced its own spice
his prescient power reached to the end
of time
his brain had spread out amongst his
body and no longer existed in his skull
the pre-worm body could protect itself
without him even consciously thinking of
it
it would react to danger violently
his body was also immune to almost all
conventional weapons
many believe that lately could not be
killed so this guy becomes a worm for
superpowers
no organism to save humanity why would
anybody want to do that
[Music]
well
about worm girl worm girl
oh you mean she on a brook of course she
at least gets
honorable mention shyanna was a girl
born on arrakis after the death of lato
ii
one day after her village is destroyed
she discovers that she has the power to
control the desert worms
the worms obey her every command it
doesn't really count though i mean
that only matters if you're in the
desert what that totally counts if
you're in a desert you're toast
i guess but she doesn't really have an
advantage anywhere else
anyway guys that's the video for today
let me know what you think
post your rankings in the comment
section below next time do scariest
monsters in dune
no the next dune video is ultimate guide
to chapter house
it's already been too long i mean of
course unless some new dune news comes
out or something
thank you so much for watching guys make
sure you like and subscribe and if you
would like to support this channel
click the paypal link in the description
hi guys there's just a couple of weeks
left to be able to order my graphic
noveltadia
get on that immediately link in the
[Music]
description
[Music]
you